اطلقت وزاره الصحه في الاردن بالشراكه مع
مؤسسات المجتمع المدني حمله كلنا ايجابيه
لتسليط الضوء على معاناه الاشخاص
المتعايشين مع فيروس الايدز وازاله
الحواجز امام وصولهم للخدمات وانهاء اوجه
عدم المساواه بحقوقهم
والمتعايش مع فايروس
من حقه ان يكون على قدم المساواه مع اي
شخص اخر لانه لا يختلف اطلاقا عن اي شخص
بشرط ان يكون هذا المتعايش يتلقى ملتزم
بالعلاجات المؤسسات الدوليه ترفعه شعار
المساوا هذا العام للاحتفال باليوم
العالمي للايدز والمهتمون في هذا المجال
يؤكدونا ان الاردن ينسجموا مع هذا الشيعار
احنا بدنا المساوا بمعنى ان نتجاوز كل
الحواجز الوسمه والتمييز والحواجز اللي
بتكون امام الاشخاص لا يطلبوا الخدمات
سواء كانوا متعايشين او اشخاص متاثرين
على الرغم من عدم وجود ارقام حقيقيه
للاشخاص المصابين بفيروس الايدز في الاردن
بسبب البصمه والتمييز الا ان وزاره الصحه
صرحت انه تم تسجيل اول اصابه ايدز في
الاردن عام
حاله تم تسجيلها طبعا جزء منهم توفى الى
رحمه الله جزء منهم لا زال همم عايش لليوم
اللي يتنقل علاج عنا في مراكزنا 310 همم
مريض على هامشي الاحتفال ناقشه خبراء في
جلسه حواريه حقوق الاشخاص المتعايشين مع
فيروس الايدز بالعمل والصحه وسبل التمتع
بها وتجسيد الشراكه بين كافه القطاعات
المعنيه